And you're a young comedian,
you're SNL for fuck's sake Jesus Christ.
We all know what that's
like behind the scenes.
Actually yeah but you
know, it's interesting.
I'm from this different era of
I'm part of his wave that came along.
We come after there's the
sixties and seventies.
You know sixties they're smoking pot
seventies they're doing cocaine.
I come along in the eighties
and I'm part of this group of writers.
It doesn't do it like we're
watching our cholesterol
you know we're like we're in
the room with people who went
into their offices maybe and
closed the door and did Coke,
but we were completely oblivious to it.
And you know, my writing
partner at the time Greg Daniels
was like you know you
can't eat right bread
it's slightly ignoring like.
Greg Daniels, who created
the office and parks
and recreation with
Mike Schur among others.
I cannot picture Greg
Daniels taking an aspirin.
No, no yeah he wouldn't, he wouldn't.
And that was my writing partner.
And I mean, I'm straight as a
narrow he straight as an arrow
where the most, it's a
ridiculous now it's a true story.
I went and had to get a
it's a couple of years
into my late night show
I had to get a physical and
insurance physical you know
for my late night show that
cause you know it's required.
So I go
and I'm getting this physical
from a doctor I don't know
the insurance company chose the doctor
and he's talking to me and
then he said, "Okay, alcohol."
And I go like, "yeah, I
mean I have some wine."
And he said, "Okay and
what drugs do you do?"
And I said, "I don't do any drugs."
And he said, "You know I'm a
doctor this is confidential
"and you need to be honest with me."
And I said, "I don't do drugs."
And he said, "You don't do cocaine."
And I said, "No I don't do cocaine."
And he said, "I've seen your show."
(laughs)